All right. So we move from the sprinting to the lightning.
Our biggest -- Beta Sprint review team recommended six
slightly longer positions which we've just seen,
and then three lightning round presentations.
I would love to ask Bookworm, the DPLA Collection Achievements
and Profiles System, and Wikicite all come up on stage,
I think we can more or less fit the whole crew,
so we have more or less of the back-and-forth action.
And if you can't fit there, maybe just stand close by,
we're going to go Bookworm and then Collection Achievement
and Profile System and then SJUR last.
All right. So the first of the lightnings is called Bookworm.
Ben Schmidt, Martin Camacho, thank you so much for being here.
All right. So I'm Ben Schmidt, I'm a graduate student in history at Princeton University,
and visiting graduate fellow at the Cultural Observatory.
I'm Martin Camacho, an undergraduate in math at Harvard.
And we're here to talk about our project,
which is Bookworm. We are a relatively smaller group,
so we focused on one thing, and that's search.
We want to talk about how you find things in the digital library.
So this is an example of the current search site, the open libraries interface
and it works like a lot of interfaces, you get about five-ten results,
and you get a bunch of metadata fields on the right side
of the screen so that you can limit the books that you're
interested in looking at. This is a good interface,
it's so good that pretty much everyone is using it nowadays.
The New York public Library's redesigned -- even commercial sites like Amazon
and Google are producing essentially the same sort of search results. These search results are good,
but only for a particular type of search engine,
when you're trying to find a few books which match your particular search terms
or you know the author of for Unocal on metadata that you're interested in.
But it's not great for exploring a huge library.
Doesn't give you a sense of the volume of these libraries, and it discourages browsing anyway,
in some ways we've re-created the closed stack library.
So we're wondering how you can create a new form of
search that will allow you to look at large groups of books at the same time,
and we started with something that the Cultural Observatory released last year,
which was the Google books and grandeur,
which is something that lets you look at -- engram, using the vast Google books collection.
We learned two things.
People are really good at finding patterns in these sorts of visual displays,
if you look at a chart like this that shows the rise of a
university library, and that its decline or something,
and the rise of the digital library in the 1990s,
that this -- clear patterns that you want to investigate
and you want to look into that motivate you to actually find these books.
We actually also learned that people complain about books and have interesting insights
about books and this sort of thing doesn't address.
It doesn't let you find out what the individual books are here because meditation per --
understrength licensing conditions can actually get at the catalog information.
So we wanted to take both of these things and put them together.
The power of the insights you can get to fulltext made
visible through compelling visualization that people can
use to find patterns with library quality metadata in an
experience that places reading books at the center of
library search interface. And this we came up with Bookworm.
I think maybe you shouldn't go to that URL quite yet,
because live demo is about to happen
and we do not have a spectacular server here.
Is the -- [Laughter] but afterwards I urge you to  try to crash at.
Our hope with a Bookworm is it helps  you will have a new
engagement with Liber is. Martin will show how this works.
-- With libraries.
All right. This is the main interface of Bookworm,
and we've tried to make  the user interface where the
user build data visualizationn where they can define the
axes and also defined a different series and the charts.
Here have searched for the word evolution
and I'm graphing it over the corpus of all books so what
I get is the graph that shows the percentage of books in
the 19th century which use the word evolution.
Suppose I'm interested in the use of the word evolution
and science. I go here, I had another group of books, go into the metadata selector,
and pick a subject science, which is in the standardization,
and every submit the query,
now I can see of course evolution is used much more
probably in science than it was on average in all books.
I can keep doing this -- so I'll add social science here.
Which is H, for some reason.
[Laughter]
You are evidently not a librarian. Exactly.
And now I can see that there's a short
and steep increase in the usage of evolution
and social sciences around 10 years after Charles R.
published origin of species around 1870
and keeps increasing until it gets to about as popular in
social sciences in about 1900.
Even if I didn't know anything about social Darwinism,
I could still kind of look at -- see something
interesting is going on here. So I want to find out more.
I can click on the graph in a certain year, say, 1880.
What pops up as a list of all the books
and social sciences published in 1880 which use the word evolution,
and this is ranked by frequency of usage of the word ask -- evolution.
I can read any of these using the open libraries awesome
online book reader getting read.
Let's read principles of sociology by Herbert Spencer.
This will pop up the book in the open Library reader.
That's the basic gist of Bookworm.
Please visit us at bookworm.culturomics.org.
Thanks so much for your time.
Great job, guys.
Wonderful job. We're going to go on without questions
and then we'll come back to the whole group with
questions and that's okay. So, Tito Sierra
and Jason Renato, the DPLA collection  profile system.
Curious to see how the graphical prepositioned -- graphical revisitation turns out.
I'm going to talk about the Beta Sprint collection achievement and profile system
and just to give you a little bit of context for this,
we begin from certain assumptions.
One assumption is that there's already a lot of cultural
heritage content online on the web.
Many different formats, from large organizations, small organizations,
and more of this content is coming online every day.
The problem that we see is that a lot of this content is distributed, it's silos.
It's not easily discoverable by search engines or really well connected.
And therefore, just because it's accessible doesn't mean it's discoverable.
Which is a scene that some of us talked about this morning.
It's unfortunate that a lot of this is really great
content that's underutilized by the general public.
So basically a layman's way of working -- looking at our
proposal is to say that what we're proposing is building
something kind of like a link in profile,
for every special library archive
or museum collection in the country.
On a more technical kind of point of view,
rather than hold a tool or a destination where websites,
what we're proposing is building basically a platform
that sympathize aggregation of collections, both big and small distributed.
And to also facilitate interoperability between these collections.
So as part of the Beta Sprint, Jason and I developed a set of wire frames.
I only have five minutes so I'm only going to show you two,
but we have a poster outside where you can see for more.
If you go to our site, you can see more of their also.
I'm going to quickly highlight some of the features of this profile system.
We came up with this concept called minimal viable profile record,
what is the minimal amount of metadata about a collection to be part of the system.
A title URL, description, and a category.
The idea is to have a really low barrier of entry so that
we can have really small collections represented in this.
But the idea, we also introduced this concept of achievements.
Basically is a little discrete pieces of metadata that
could be attached to the profile to
extend the profile in many different ways,
so we don't begin from an assumption of a single monolithic data structure.
We feel that you could have perhaps 100 different
achievements which tackle different aspects of using the
collection, and that each collection can pick
and choose achievements that make sense for that particular collection.
In this particular example,
you can think of these -- as widgets. A collection
and a visitor in for what widget to collect data about
the actual physical collection that that represents.
Perhaps maybe encouraging access to the fit -- to the physical collection
and also the last one here is just an example of -- we call it robot friendly,
and it's metadata to help with crawling.
We propose a very open collaborative model,
so there's not a single set of curators doing this,
but it's like Wikipedia, very open.
Collection managers can update these records were volunteers,
people in the general public can contribute to it.
Although we're showing screenshots of the website,
the primary benefit of this is to help other third-party services ill services that aggregate
and reuse some of this content,
so you would have API access, to the collection.
This is one way of doing it through JSON,
but one can man in -- imagine a different serialization for getting at the score information.
And finally,
this is a screenshot to sort of show our brainstorm on
where these -- this idea of achievements can go,
so we have several categories. Or motion, content, so content reuse,
maybe you could have something like teaching tools,
to help people engage with collections.
A donate widget to help people get funds for their
collections, current awareness tools like RSS feeds,
analytics tools, any number of ideas here.
The idea is that a platform that allows these sort of metadata elements to grow
and be attached to the collections.
So just to summarize our proposal,
rather than think about the DPLA as a site or two or destination,
we envision it as a networking platform that can help
cultural organizations both big and small maximize
the use and discovery of their content. With that, thank you.
[Applause]
Thank you, Tito and Jason. That was evocative and thoughtful.
Thank you. Last of the lightning sprinters,
another of our great friends, Samuel Klein
but SJ to me. From what the media.
One of the most important wiki manaics out there.
He's going to fabless of final lightning sprint.
Thanks a lot. This is an amazing audience
and I wanted to mention after the discussions earlier
today, John is rightly proud that this is both public
and private partner. This is grassroots and institutional libraries
and patrons from all different -- I'm immensely honored
to be here and I think that we can do some the tremendous.
Is going to be a supershort lightning talk.
This is one of those simple ideas that four different
groups came to from different angles at the same time
and we said, you know, let's do it. Better yet,
not only is it a civil idea but it's easy to -- easily
distribute a bull amongst the ball.
And it's simply to upgrade the analog citation to make
people to get into rich understanding of the knowledge we have today.
We talked about what to do with physical collections and digitization,
but most work tomorrow is going to be digital. It's going to be self published.
And Wikipedia is an example of what you can get out of
that kind of teaming, thriving, living environment.
You need to know what is a reliable source that is hard to.
Any editor on Wikipedia with a source in his pocket as a godlike power and think are the most people don't know it.
So unfortunately,
there are any good canonical ways to find out whether a
source is reliable in a given context
or even how reliable it is in general
or to collect the comment about a source
and to kind of cluster them by where they're using very as topics.
So our proposal is to develop a wiki for Kurt -- for crowd sourcing discussions
and citations in general in their contexts -- sorry about that --
and our model is to build a central wiki that draws from
her post stories, links back -- repositories.
Links back -- I am not a Mac user, can you tell?
Yes, please. [Laughter]
And then, implements an API that allows anyone who has their own
private or sort of specialized uses of citation information to
develop their own team wiki that might include private
data that they can't share with everyone.
And that allows them to push back any updates
or new information that they have to share with the world.
We have all this in more detail.
I know this is a very small on his poster outside,
and we would love to take comments and suggestions from people.
There are a bunch of matchups that have already been made.
We came up with this idea a couple years ago but really
got into it this past spring,
and throughout a call for people to suggest matchups.
Using social is you to capture oral histories that are.
Right now it's hard to generate permanent citations for oral histories.
Is being used to Cory available citation data to show you
everything in a field that you have used elsewhere within a group.
On Wikipedia,
people are going to use it to cache webpages
and figure out which pages should be cached,
because there is a tremendous amount of link rot online,
and what to have figured out how people visualize that,
you can automatically cache them as used in what you
The audience and people who benefit from it are often editors
and readers as well as general researchers,
people who want to resolve citations for particular quotes,
and they don't quote they're not sure what comes from, they could pick
and arbitrate I can they could like to send to have it resolved through the cloud of existing citations.
And for librarians
and people who curtly have access to data,
we would love to talk to people who do their own citation analysis.
We are doing a couple of citation analyses to figure out how people use different classes of sources.
And how people respond to what are negative quality
references and what they do with them. Thank you very much.
[Applause]
All right. Questions
or comments for any of the lightning round sprinters?
I see somebody has a mic. Yes?
I have a question for the MINT.  I like your idea.
-- Bookworm team.
Do you see if it has any application beyond the academic
world?
Yeah,
I actually think one of the things that we learned from
Google engrams is these visualizations are things that do
have a really broad range of appeal.
So when engrams it came out,
there were something like 1 million queries in the first
24 hours. The majority of those were outside of academia,
places like journalism to be sure,
but it is something that beyond just academics,
it's a very compelling way I think,
for a lot of people to think about problems as having
historical patterns that can be solved.
I don't think it solves all search problems obviously,
but it's good for more people than I expected.
As we pass the mic, one conception of the DPLA,
and we'll hear more about this with the work streams of
them is we could imagine developing a series of services, open services,
where people develop things that are for specialized
audiences, which are not exclusive, right?
I think the concept we've been talking about of interoperability
and open APIs is to say we need lots of people to focus on different use cases
and different kinds of communities and Bookworm may or may not be limited to one.
Does a great lot of post does a great blog post last
night by Dan, who responds to Bookworm ,
there's a lot of conversation for whom these services will best apply.
Other comments on the lightning round?
I did not expect the silence after the screw.
I'm going to use the moderators prerogative to comment.
Richard Irvin,
do you mind being called called in the audience?
You're an expert on linked open data among many other
things and this has been thrown around in a figure,
this is a mixed crowds of people may intuitively know why
a link to open data is important
and one thing people seem to know, it is a given
and I wouldn't mind being given on why it is important in your view.
Thank you. I was getting called called on this, wasn't I.?
In one way, there is a lot of buzz around link data
and output it as part of a continuum and for many years,
it was a different way of expressing descriptions we have been doing before,
structures that appear as catalog records
and it is the same kind of metadata we have been doing in
the community for a long time.
Part of the changes being able to try to identify
and name those things in ways that were reliable.
And finding simpler ways that don't mean that you have to
have a very sacked record structure by finding much more
creative ways to express the will to say about these resources
and be able to relate them in ways that let them travel into things like the ShelfLife
and ExtraMUROS project to start building things between people and libraries
and the ideas people have about collections and objects. Since that is obvious.
Civic in the course of the next 18 months,
what it means to have a good working people have ideas,
many of us take it as received wisdom that is a very
important conceptual -- that we heard across otherwise.
Soon there are some differences in how linked data in the
cataloging we have done before
and I -- will come back to it.
We can go to a break early and because I cold call,
anybody from the Sprint data review team that wants to comment on Bradley,
you have volunteered more than what were bargaining for
an end to make this space available.
One alternate question.
I guess if I asked how many of you have edited Wikipedia
before, you would raise your hands.
Can we ask?
And everyone raises their hand because you have done Google search
and they go to Wikipedia as a consumer of information we are not sure about the veracity
and how can we help Wikipedia and one thing is,
working through a book scanning project and work,
we can hover over a sentence and Wikipedia
and contextualize that automatically by searching through
the text and books that would go over to the site
and Wikipedia's, it has to be neutral
and has a neutral point of view
and how are you supposed to have a natural exposition of
a topic if you don't understand the scope
or how the citations fit into the literature more
probably so one of the things the wiki site is supposed
to help editors of Wikipedia do is figure out how to do
the initial exposition and as a consumer,
you can go there and actually verify that is true,
you can go to SI
and develop your own interpretation of the authority
and reliability of the source I just want to express that
because a lot of people use it
and the two PLA has a lot of professional potential for helping in that space.
Soon as he that is reciprocal
and it is no secret that we are surprised that both of
these projects are being funded at the highest level so I
have two tiny closing comments
and one is that the data Sprint review panel had the same
experience that many of us did in looking at the 39
amazing submissions and to be clear,
there is no reward for these people other than an
obligation to sit on the stage in common talk,
they promised to give all of the electro-property to the
DPLA and there is no  monetary reward of any sort,
this is an extraordinary outpouring of volunteerism that
those well for America and the world of this project.
I want to thank everybody who submitted a data Sprint
and we could have gone on for hours and hours of please join me in thanking the entire Beta Sprint team.
[Applause]
I hope very much a result of the data Sprint will be
rolled into a DPLA
and these projects will also extend on their own in many respects,
because CDs are independent efforts was very passionate
wonderful people behind them in one such project that the
review panel identified in her notes,
there are two pages, a public domain registry project
and this is one they flagged as an important
and interesting one and her partner,
Charles from Harvard is working on
and is totally relevant
and interesting annulus collaborators
and was not chosen for this presentation but there are
lots of things like that that are worth reviewing in looking at.
And since this is my last time with a microphone today,
I wanted to make one dangerous thing of thinking one person in particular,
there is a amazing human interoperability thing going on
between the archive staff for there is one person on the
last year has worked hard on this than anyone else which
is Rebekah Heacock anywhere here,
we need to give her some applause. [Applause].
We are working on a nickname for Rebecca Hancock of
anyone has a good one, but she is the bomb,
that is all I have to say
and we will see you back here at 3:45 for the final
session and thank you so much.